ではよろしくお願いします
はい ではご質問とかいろいろ
質問の場合はまあ何でもいいということで
自由に聞きたいことがございましたら質問をなさってください
じゃあ左の前の あ どうもこんにちは
あの死刑についてどう思いますか？ ん？ 死刑
あ  まああまりいいこととはね
まあいい 言いにくいんですけど
しかしね 人を殺してしまえば
その人はこの社会で 人間の中でね
自分で生きる権利は失っているんです
死刑するのはね 法律やら色々なことですからね
死刑に決めるんで罪でしょうかということは
おそらくわかりません
ないだと ないとは思いたいんですけどね
裁判の方でね 死刑決めなくちゃいけないし
しかし 人がそこを実行しなくちゃいけないんですね
それってあんまりいいことじゃないんですね
やっぱり 立て法律だといってもね
とにかくまあそういうややこしいことなんですけどね
仏教的に言えば まあとにかく人はせっかく生まれてきたんだからね
まあ自分の寿命が終わるまでにね
まあ生かしてあげた方がよろしいと思います
しかし 社会の一員として生きる権利は失ってますね
そういうところだとは思います
我々は殺人した人を死刑にしてもしなくても
本人が犯した罪の結果が受けますので
特別に我々困らなくてもいいということになります
そんなところでございます
私の意見は  はい 次の方がよろしいですか
右の前の  はい こちら  よろしくお願いします
ありがとうございました
あの仏教のですね 教えとか実践で自分を改善ということをできるんじゃないかなと思ってやってきたと思いますけども
自分の周囲のですね 人を変えることはできるでしょうか
自分は変えることができます
人は変えられません  一応できると思った方がいいと思いますね
この自分を変えるとか何とかとか
我々言ってますけど そもそも自分というものも存在するものではなくて
因果法則にとって成り立っているものだから
一時的なんですね それであの
今私がここにいるということと
皆様との関係で成り立ってるんですね
私はあの後の部屋にいる時とは全く違う人間になるんですね
こちらに来たら 電車に乗ったらまた別な人間になったりするんですね
だから自分の人格っていうものは
いつでも環境によって変わったり変わったりするもので
いつでもその場で成り立つんです
そういうことだから 自分がかなり立派で落ち着いて
明るい気持ちで優しい心でいると
そこで周りと影響の組み合わせで周りも良くなります
そういうことで 私たちはいい人間でいることは
自分に関係ある人々に対しては良い結果になるんですね
その人々も穏やかになります
気持ちよくなります それで影響を受けて変わることは当然あり得るんです
因果法則から見れば まあ何でも変えられます
自我で人に説教すると
なかなか反抗だけなんですね
受けてもらわないんですね
だから人に何か言う場合は
よく仏教でいうやり方がありまして
相手が納得することが大事なんですね
だからあなたはどう思いますか？っていう質問
これ お釈迦様の経典ではいつでもいつでもあるんですよ
あなたに質問しますから
自分が好きなように答えてくださいと
で お釈迦様質問する場合は
あなたはどう思いますか？ということで答え出してもらうんですね
面白いことは ものすごい難しい内容までお釈迦様の話の中で発展していくんですよ
発展していくと よくよく見ると喋ってるのはお釈迦様ではなくて
相手になっちゃうんですね
お釈迦様は質問を出すと出して
相手が答えていくんですね
全く仏教を知らない人が
それで終わってくると
相手がよく仏教を理解して
もう出家までお願いするところまで発展するんですね
だから そういうやり方で私たちももうお釈迦様の完全な真似はできませんだけど
まあ人にあなたこうしなさい
こうしなさいではなくて
どう思いますか？ということで
いうやり方で人にアドバイスしたり教えたりする場合は
もう当然変わると思います
ありがとうございます
はい  はい 質問かな この前に
右奥の すいません ありがとうございます
近頃ですね 仕事で周りからの大変なプレッシャーとか
会社からのプレッシャーで心を病む人がかなり多いと思うんですよ
そこで あの心の予防というか
の仕方とか あとなっちゃった場合にどう仏教の考え方を活かすとか
そういう アドバイスがあれば教えていただきたいのですが
で あの人がね プレッシャーかけちゃうと一応能力は低下するでしょうね
だから周りがね 相手にプレッシャーをかけるということが
周りが人のアドミニストレーションと管理はね
できないということなんですよ
正しい管理者っていうのは
能力を引き起こしてもらうんですね
いわゆるプロダクションがね
ものよくできるようにするんですよ
で 元気じゃない人は元気にさせる
能力ない人が能力が向上できるように雰囲気を作ってあげたりして
励ましてあげることがアドミニストレーターという管理者の仕事なんですよ
しかし わがまま主観でやれやれとかね
もっと儲かるようにしなさいとか
強引に言ってもね だから会社潰しているのはあなた方だよという態度取ったらどうでしょうかと思いますよ
で 社員たちにも能力が向上しないようにストレス
プレッシャーをかけちゃったりして
仕事はなんか苦しい環境だと地獄のような環境を作ったりしてね
会社環境っていうのは
なんか我が家でいるような気分がいいところでなければ
もう仕事をする気持ちにならないんですね
だから今質問の場合は自分がどうするのかということ質問でしたから
やっぱり まあこう考えればね
この連中はバカだと こんなストレスかけちゃうと
これ真に受けちゃうと自分もバカになるんだと
自分が楽しく明るく仕事をするんだと
自分がもう自分にもプライドあるんだからね
もうみんなびっくりするほど仕事をしてやるそうと
自分の能力はあるんだ
あるんだよ だからもう言われるの
言うのは大きなお世話よと言われ
言われなくても仕事をするんだそうとね
ということで この楽しみで仕事をしなくちゃいけないんですね
よく覚えてほしいポイントは
楽しみがあると心が喜びを感じると
いくらでも能力というのは向上するんですよ
だからプレッシャーをかけるのはとんでもないことなんです
プレッシャーではなくて
なんか雰囲気を引き立ててあげなくちゃいけないんですね
ああ なかなか頑張ってるなとかね
冗談でいいんだよ あんたよく頑張るんだけど
結果ゼロでしょ？とかね
冗談言ってからかって楽しくさせてあげると
心が成長しますよ だからプレッシャーをかけ
いろんなことを言われても言われても
もうよくわかります よくわかりますと言いながら
あまり気にしない方がいいと思いますよね
なぜならば 楽しみがないと心は成長しない
能力は向上しないんです
はい 以上です  次の質問の方
これは前の方 何回  失礼いたします
理解は信仰に勝るということをおっしゃっておられましたけれども
その理解というのは私たちにもできるのでしょうか
というのは わかっていてできないことが結構ありまして
私はお寺で生活していたことがあるんですけれども
そこで早起きして掃除をしていても怒られるからずっとやってこれたんです
暴力を振るわれたりもした
今考えると その人たちが暴力振るってくれたことで
わかってはなかったんだけども
そういう習慣が身について
あとで あ こういうことだったんだなってのがわかるということもあるんですけども
そういう意味で理解するように伝える以外に
何か暴力というのはよくないかもしれないんですけど
違った方法で伝えるということはやってらっしゃったりするのでしょうか
聞かせていただけたらと思います
とにかく理解に勝るものは存在しませんよ
で 暴力はね 暴力的なものね
お寺で暴力振るうわけじゃないんですけど
日本のお寺でもね まあ暴力ような顔をしてやってますけど
あの それは結構よくないと思いますね
理解に勝るものはないんで
理解はできますよ 例えば
自分には大事な仕事があって
朝早く起きなくちゃいかない
例えばもう早く朝一番の電車に乗らなくちゃいけないとか
ことがあったらちゃんと起きるでしょうね
自分ではもうわかってますよ
責任持ってますからね
だから理解は誰にでもできますよ
だって人間でしょうに
なんで人間で生まれて
自分をね もう別に見下してみるんですかね
それはとんでもないことなんです
人間ならできるんです
今日の場合でも 私は無常やら苦やら因果法則やら
とても難しいことを紹介したんですよ
しかし 理解できるような感じでね
だから理解に勝るものはないんです
相手がやりたくないと責任持ってない
理解してないんだから
お寺で朝起こすためにいろいろ強引なことをやったりはするんですね
こういうことできますよ
例えば 自分がちょっと気が弱くて
まあ朝弱いと起きられないんだと
その場合はもうお願いしますからね
暴力振るってでもね 氷水をかけてでもいいんだから起こしてくださいと
というふうに自分の方で頼んでおくこととは構いませんよ
自分の弱みを理解していて
しかし責任感じたらそれはなくなっちゃうんです
とにかく で 我々の状況でもね
修行に入っちゃうと 大体朝三時に起きるというのが普通なんです
しかし 誰も監督しないんです
やっぱり西洋の人々が書いた本なんか読んでみて
あの これって大変厳しいんだと
朝三時だと道場ではとかね
で このヨーロッパ人にお互いに
だからしかし心配することはないんだよと
瞑想したければ道場に入ってください
なぜならば 自分の部屋には誰も来ないんだよと
だから寝たければ寝られますよと
いうことを書いてあったんですけど
私は何やこの人々と思ったんですけど
我々現地の人々は 誰が頼まなくたって
もう三時に起きてるんですよ
一日目は厳しいんですよ
三時起きたってもうなんか厳しいんだけど
すぐすぐはみんな頑張ってるし
自分も自分の気持ちで修行するために行ったんだから
もうみっともないと思っちゃうんですね
もう四時になっても起きてないことは
自分でそう思う みっともないんだと
それでもうちょうど三時になるともうビシビシ起きて
もう修行を始めているんですね
そういうことで 一人一人が自分の自由
自分の人権 尊厳を大事にするならば
何の問題もないんです
もう何でも理解でいった方がいいと私は思いますよ
暴力はもうやっても意味がないんですよ
私も子供たちなんか勉強しないと
時々怒鳴ったり脅したりしますけど
まるっきり効き目がないんです
全くもダメなんです その代わりにもういくらいたずらして悪いことしたっても
それに怒ることなく では勉強でもしてやろうかなとかね
と言っちゃうと なんかニコッと笑って始まるんです
だから そうやって楽しく理解してもらってやればよろしいんだ
あまりも言うことを聞かないと
私はやると言うでは 君たちは勝手にやってくださいと
私は気にしませんと 勉強してもしなくても結構だと
なぜか知ってるのかと
大人になったら私がいないしね
勝手にどうなったっても知ったことじゃないんだよと
いうふうに もうもうどんなひどい目に遭ったっても
知ったものじゃないんだと言って
自分がもう責任放棄するんですね
そうすると 我々の人生やと思ってくれるでしょう
でしょうと思いますね
ですから この暴力で強引で脅しで人を動かせるということが初めからよくないんですよ
理解でやるしかないんです
他の宗教もね 日本の寺もそうでしょう
他の宗教もまず暴力 暴力って脅し
脅し 脅し 脅しでね 神を信じなきゃ永遠に地獄に落ちるぞとかね
冗談じゃないんだよと思いますけどね
ではなくて 我々はね お互い優しくしたらかっこいいでしょうと
とてもクールだよと 人を脅したり
怒ったり 殴ったりするのは
もう犬猫もやっていることだからね
格好悪いんだよと もう怒った人に怒るよりは
怒らないでニコッと笑うことはすごい大変かっこいいことやと
なかなかできんやと そういうふうに理解していくと
じゃあ俺もかっこいいことやってやるかなと思っちゃうでしょうね
そうやって良いことをしながら
自分では何て言いますか
まあ気持ちいいんですね
頑張ってるんだと すごいことやってるんだと
そういうふうに幸福の方向へ人が行かなくちゃいけないんですよ
嫌々でやったってもね
何も幸福を感じませんよ
脅されて毎日 例えばイスラム教だったら 1 日 5回お祈りするんですからね
脅されて脅されて 毎日 5回お祈りしたっても
気分がいいわけじゃないんですよ
ではなくて もうお祈りしてもしなくてもどうでもいいやということで
祈りする方がかっこいいんだとなってくると
自分の意思で祈りすることになるんですね
その人は幸福を感じるんですよ
そういうことで もう理解ですよ
全部できると思います
はい 頑張ってみてください
はい 次の方 次の質問がある方お越しください
はい  よろしくお願いします
仕事と怠けというところについての考え方を教えていただきたいんですけれども
先ほどの方の質問と の内容にもちょっと近いんですが
今仕事が例えばもうずっと残業だとか徹夜とかずっときつくて
自分の時間が全然なくて
ずっと頑張ってるような人がいると
このままでは全然幸せじゃないと
で 仕事を変えて ちょっと田舎暮らしみたいな形でつましい仕事にして
自分の時間を取り戻しましたと
それでそのできた時間で自分の好きなことをしたりだとか
例えば散歩をするような時間を作ったりだとか
そういうようなことして幸せになりましたと
でもその分 前より仕事は減ってます
そういったような時に
それは怠けっていると言えるのかどうか
仕事に対して怠けっていうのをどのように考えるべきなのかというのを教えていただきたいと思います
まず理解してほしいところがございます
この怠けという病気が一切の生命にあるんです
ない人はないんです なぜかというと
生きることは苦痛なんです
そこで何かやったんだからといって
苦しみだけは消えません
前も言ったんだから お腹が空くと苦しいし
だからってご飯食べたらだからって楽になるかというとそうじゃなくて
満腹で苦しいんですよ
で 疲れたら苦しいし それで寝るでしょうに
寝たら寝た苦しみが出てくるんですね
気持ち悪くなっちゃうんですね
そういうことで 我々はまあ何やっても苦しいという人生やってますよ
そこで なんかほっとしたいと
実はやりたくないんだっていう気持ちが当然出てくるんです
例えば できれば朝ご飯は作りたくないんですよ
しかし 作らなきゃダメだから作ってるんです
できればご飯は食べたくないんです
しかし 食べなきゃダメだから食べてるんです
そういうことで我々やってるんな
どんなことを見たっても
できればやりたくないんですよ
だってそのことも苦だからね
赤ちゃんがキャーと泣くと
お母さんが本当はできれば寝たいんですよ
疲れてるんだから しかし
寝ているわけにはいきませんだから起きておっぱいあげたりするんですよ
もう楽しくてしょうがないわけじゃないんです
やりたくてやりたくて
お母ちゃんのおっぱいあげたくてあげたくて
そんなことないんです
できればもう寝かしてくれという気持ちなんですよ
あるいはもう電車に乗っていった
でも突然赤ちゃんが泣き出しちゃうと
もうもうおっぱいあげなくちゃいけないんですよ
もう人がいるんだとか
そんなこと考えられないんですね
やっぱり電車でおっぱいあげるお母ちゃん
お母さんがおっぱいあげてますよ
本当はやりたくないんですよ
そういうわけで よく理解しましょう
人生っていうのは 我々何やってもできればやりたくないことなんですよ
やってるの しかし もうしょうがなく
仕方がなく 避けられないんだからやってるんです
勉強する時もそうでしょ
本当はできればやりたくないんですよ
しかし 勉強しなかったらしなかったらダメだからやってるんです
そこを理解しておけば
その問題に答えが見えてくると思います
で 会社は嫌だから もう怠けたいんだからと何とかって
もう田舎に行ったとかね
そういうのは正しい答えじゃないんで
そこは能力の問題なんですよ
頑張っても頑張っても
自分には十分仕事をできないならば
自分で納得いく仕事をできないならば
会社を辞めた方がいいんです
ただ怠けで逃げたっても意味がないんです
それで答えはこういう答えなんですよ
どうせやるんだから楽しくやろうよと
例えばお母さん お母さんが朝 3時半に起きたとする
赤ちゃんにおっぱいあげるために
まあどうせあげなくちゃあかんだからね
逃げられないでしょ だからそこを楽しんで
ニコニコと笑いながら
で おっぱいあげて寝かしてあげて
自分も一緒に寝ちゃえばいいんです
で 私はあるお母さんたちに言ったんですよ
疲れてるって言ったら
あんた疲れる必要ないでしょ
赤ちゃんずっとたくさん寝ているでしょうと
その時一緒に寝ちゃいなさいと
そうするともう結構仕事できるようになりますと
自分が朝早く起きて 夜遅くまでずっと仕事ばっかりやったりして
そうすると子育てできなくなるんですね
赤ちゃんは夜も来ますからね
そういうことで 赤ちゃんはもう朝9時半であろうと関係なく寝ちゃうと
一緒にお母さんもちょこちょこと寝てみる
そういう感じで楽しくやればいいんだよっていうことなんです
ですから 私たちはどうしてやらなくちゃいけないことがありますから
先に進んでやっちゃう
もう楽しみにする そうなってくると怠けに打ち勝つことはできるんですね
なんかやることないのかという気分で生活するんです
いつでもはい 次に何 何
何でしょうかねとかね
そうやってもう次から次へといろいろ仕事を計画立てたりして
やることを作ったりして
もう何でもかんでも明るく楽しくやるしかないんですよ
怠けに打ち勝つためには
仕事から逃げたっても逃げられませんし
田舎に行ったっても 田舎の田舎で頑張らなくちゃいけないし
自分好きなことをやるということは正しい答えじゃないんですよ
物事はあなた好きかあなた嫌いかっていうことはどうでもいいんです
物事については 世界に必要なのは完璧に仕事をする人なんです
だから 自分に完璧にできる仕事なら
好きか嫌いか置いといて
自分がプロですから そのことについてはそれやればいいんです
だから まず我々は好きなことをやりたいという気持ちは間違いなんです
それ捨てましょう 仕事には好き嫌いは関係ないんです
あなたできるかできないかっていうことは関係あるんですよ
例えば芸術家がね もう外科がかっこいいなと
あれやりたいなと思ったってもね
やめてほしいんですよ
腕のいい外科が外科医が手術してくればいいんです
私 やりたくない やりたくないという話ではないんですよ
プロはやりたい やりたくないじゃないんですよ
淡々とやっちゃうんですね
だから我々はみんな人間が何かのプロにならなくちゃいけないんですね
それで人類を助けて 自分も助けてもらって生活するんです
ですから やりたい仕事をやりたくない仕事は区別は捨てて
能力ある仕事はやるんだそうと言って
自分の能力はどこに生かせるのかということだけ考えればよろしいんです
それから どんな仕事でも本当はやりたくないのにやるものだから
楽しくやりましょうということで
怠けについてはなんとか乗り越えられると思います
はい 以上です  ありがとうございました
はい 次の質問の方は 右の奥
すいません 質問させてください
長老のお話は非常に新鮮で
非常にストレートで 僕らに響いてくるものがあると思うのですが
お釈迦様の教えは一つだと思うんですが
その解釈とか実践とかで
様々な事情により仏教というのは上座部と大乗と二つに分かれていると思うんですが
その大きくその大乗仏教について
まず長老はどのように見ていらっしゃったかということが質問の一つで
もう一つ 特に日本での伝統的な仏教教団について
長老はどのように見ていらっしゃるのかというのをちょっとお伺いできればと思っております
よろしくお願いします
大乗仏教についてのこの私の意見ではなくてね
客観的にいろいろ学問
学者として見てみると
大乗仏教っていうのは
釈迦牟尼ブッダの教えではなくて
いろんな方々が開発したそれぞれの思想体系なんですね
だからまあ そのところで終わっちゃいますが
世の中ではね いろいろ思想体系ありますからね
そこはまあ自由でいいんじゃないかなと思いますよ
まあ経済学好きな人を見て
歴史は好きな人もいるし
考古学好きな人もいるし
まあそれぞれ勝手にやってくださいと
歴史よりは考古学の方が優れているんだとかね
考古学よりは地理学の方が優れているんだとか
それはもう話はちょっと違いますし
変でしょうしね そういうわけで
大乗仏教というのはたくさんなりますしね
宗派としては 各宗派は各思想体系を持っているんですね
それで私が釈迦牟尼ブッダという歴史的な方が何を語ったかという
そこを紹介しているんです
人々はまあ 気に入るものを選べばいいんです
そういうところだとは思います
しかし まあ私はまあ断言的にね
まあ釈迦牟尼ブッダの教えは科学的で
現代的で 現代的ではなくて
時代を超えているものであると
そこの一部だけをとって特別な思想体系を作ると
それはブッダの教えではなくて
例えば日蓮の教え 親鸞の教えとか
そういう風になっちゃうんですね
道元の教えとかね 中国でもそういうふうに自分がある特別な教えを作るんですね
それで宗教学的な立場でいうと
同じ仏教というよりは別々宗教だと思った方が正しいんですよ
例えば 親鸞様の教えを実践する人と
日蓮の教えを実践する人は
やっていることはまるっきり違うことをやってますからね
まあ鐘が鳴るんだから
みんな葬式だけはみんな同じことをやってますけどね
それ分かりきってるんですね
宗派が変わっても葬式のやり方は同じとかね
それ以外は別々な宗教なんです
私 個人的には仏教という前で
日蓮教 親鸞教とか言った方がより学術的ではないかなと思ったりもします
しかし 誰が正しいという話ではないので
それぞれ人は自分なりの教えをまあ頑張ればいいんじゃないかなと思います
要は 生きることは苦しいし
我々には精神的な悩み
苦しみがいっぱいあるし
じゃあ生きるものの要求に誰が答えるのかということなんです
お腹が空いてご飯を食べたくて食べたくてたまらない人が
洋服屋さんに行ってお金で洋服を買うのは自由ですが
その選択は正しいなのかと
お金...お腹が空いてものすごく苦しんでいる人がお金があるならば
普通なら食堂に行くでしょ
行ってご飯買うんですよ
洋服買えないわけじゃないし
買ってはいけないということもちょっと言いづらいんです
あるいは おもちゃ屋さんに行っておもちゃを買ったと
しかし おもちゃは買ったのは良かったんだけど
あなたの問題は解決してないんだよと
ですから この私たち一人一人が
自分が生きている上で起こす問題に
悩みに 苦しみに答えが必要とするならば
お釈迦様にお釈迦様に聞いてください
ただ 別に何か神秘的なことやら
何とか何だらかんだら非科学的ないろいろ好きだったら
それぞれ店では売ってます
瞑想はもう美容のために私は美しくなりたいんだと
だから瞑想したいんだというならば
そのためにも瞑想を売っている店があるんです
私たちの場合は 人間にはある
具体的にずっと永遠に生きる上で起こる問題には
まあ最終的な答えを出してやるぞというのお釈迦様の教えなんですね
人はどちらを選ぶかということは
その人の自由だと思います
以上です  はい 次 よろしくお願いします
えっと 不殺生戒に関することでちょっと伺いたいことがあるんですけれども
今の日本だと何見ても貯金だとか作品だとか名品だとかよく書いてありまして
そういうものを使っているとき
ちょっと不殺生戒を破っているような気がして
ピタッと手が止まってしまうことなどがあるんですけれども
そういうものは使用を避けた方がいいのでしょうか
また そういうもので細菌などを殺してしまったりしたら何か悪い結果を負うでしょうか？よろしくお願いします
うん 自分の体はやっぱり綺麗にしておかなくちゃいけないんですね
自分の健康のためにね
それは殺生とか何だらかではなくてね
自分が清潔でいるということは
まあ一応それなりには必要だと思いますよ
もう社会の殺菌を殺してやるぞと思ったら
みんな死んでしまいますね
殺生するとかえって逆襲されますから
だから院内感染とかね
薬が効かない病気で喜んでいるでしょう
みんな あまりそこは良くないんですよ
怒りで 憎しみで まあきれいな環境でみんな健康で生きていられるように配慮をするということが慈しみに基づいたことで
ですから 夏は蚊が出るのは嫌なら
まあ最初から水たまりとかなんとかとかなくしておいて
ゴミをきれいにして きれいな環境を作っておけば
まあたまたま蚊が 1匹 2匹ぐらいできたっても
まあそれはそれで関係ないし
そういう風にお互い共存する社会が現れてきます
まあ殺して殺して自分自分だけ生き延びてやるぞということは逆襲されます
生きていられなくなります
一番いい例っていうのは
この院内感染することで
とても危険なウイルスじゃなくて
細菌ですね バクテリアが出てきて
もう火傷死にかけるわ
もう焼いてしまう限りはなくならないんだからね
じゃあ病院で中ずっと火をつけますかね
それだったら殺菌してやろうと思って
ガスバーナーでずっと壁やら何でもね
床とかね そういうことになりますからね
まあ基本的にはみんな共存できる環境を作りましょうという気持ちで頑張れば
なんとか殺生解にはならないんじゃないかなと思います
はい 次に質問のある方
前にいるみたいな  すみません
なんかうまく喋れたらいいなと思いながら忘れそうなんですけど
こんにちは えっと 秋葉原の事件ありましたよね
あれ 私は母親として この仏教スマナサーラ長老
私の娘も救われましたので
本当にあの子にスマナサーラ長老というか
この仏教 無常であるということをですね
知っておれば あんなことにならなかったなと思って
とても胸が痛かったんですね
で 一言ではなかったんですね
そして私はそのことについて
スマナサーラ長老にちょっと秋葉原のことについてお話を伺いたいのと
やっぱり子供とどうしても割愛だと言いながらも
子供のことをどうしても親離れ子離れ
子離れできない自分がまだここにいるんですけれども
どうしたら子離れできるかっていうこともあれなんですけども
子供と生涯仲良く暮らせることをちょっと教えていただきたいなと思います
私がしたいと思うのは
いつも何か心配ごとを心配して
そして何かものをプレゼントしたりとか
電話したりとかって 子供のが嫌だ
嫌だったいなという 私は自立したいなというところをいつもなんか分かっていながら
言いながらも邪魔してる
まだ自分がまだ あの ことを本当に今示したいのに
なんか不安なんですね
だからいつまでも子供とそういう関係じゃなくて
仲良く生涯いける方法をちょっと私に喝ください
それとあともう一つは
副大臣ともCO2なんかでとても暗そうな
暗そうな顔をなさっている時に
政治家は素晴らしい方たちとお会いして
お話をちょっと伺えばいいのといつも思うんですけども
この日本は本当に仏教
仏教国であっても 諸宗教をもう一度
本当に学校教育の中の道徳とか倫理の中に入れてもらわないと
これは大変なことになるなと秋葉原の時に強く思いました
その点についてちょっと教えてください
うん 第一っていうのは
私に元話させよということになりますから
起きた出来事にすると私はあまりガチャガチャ言わない主義なんですが
秋葉原で犯罪を起こした人が
私がずっと皆様に言っていることは
ただ例を出してくれたんですね
人間というのは私が悪くない
悪いのはあなたたちですよと
その調子ばっかりなんですね
そこはとんでもないんですよ
私が悪くない 私が悪く悪くないとかね
その人は何言ったかわかりませんだけど
もうテレビのニュースだけで判断すると
自分がまずモテない 自分がモテないことはもう女たちが悪いという通しなんですね
冗談じゃないんですけどね
どんな男でもそれなりの頑張ればね
誰かにはもうモテますけど
まあ自分が選んだ仕事だから
この仕事きついんだとかね
冗談でしょうに だからもういつでももう
じゃあ会社が悪い 仕事場が悪いんだったら出ていけばいいでしょうに
だからもう自分が正しいんだからと思ってるんだから
どこか会社に入ったら
会社がこのバカのために改良しなくちゃいけないんですね
きつい仕事を辞めたりとかね
ある女性の方がね もう文句言ってきた方で
仕事はきついね どういう仕事かと
まあ新しい この単純な作業なんですけど
品物管理のデータインプットすることですよと
パソコンにそれやりたくないとかね
きついとか じゃああんた何言ってるのかと
こんな単純な仕事でいいんじゃないかと
だから会社が他の人を雇わなくちゃいかないので
この女性の方が好きなことをやらせてくれると思ってるんですね
どこまで勘違いかと だったら雇う必要もないよ
雇われたら雇う主が言う仕事をするのは当たり前でしょうに
そのためにお金くれてるでしょうに
私は言ったのは あなたは倉庫でいるかもしれませんし
だから家からでも何かシーツとか何か持っていって
机にそれを敷いて 自分で花ね
たとえ 100円の花でもいいんだから
机にその花 1つ立てて
気持ちよくマイホームの気分で仕事をしなさいよと
それしか答えがないんだよと
世の中はいつでも私が悪くない
世間が悪い 社会が悪い
あれが悪い これが悪いと言って答えがないでしょうに
例えば日本の政府が悪いと決めると
じゃあ政府を変えられますかね
そのシステムを そんなこと変えられないでしょうに
だからまあ私たちはもう自分が適応するしかないんだ
ダーウィンさんもそういうこと言ってるでしょうに
もう適応するんですよ
適応できない人には生きていられないのは当たり前なんですね
だから夏が悪いんじゃなくて
我々は夏に適応するんです
冬が悪いんじゃなくて
冬に適応するんです こういう人々は
冬を夏に変えて欲しがるんですね
夏を冬に変えたがって欲しがるんです
何考えているんですかね
それであべこべ思考で問題が起こるんですよ
だから私はずっと言っていることが
皆様は信じたくなければ
秋葉原の事件がとてもいい例なんです
あべこべ思考でどれぐらい危険なのかと
人が人を殺したくなりますよ
その場合は自分の敵とか
自分の女を奪った人とか
自分の奥さんと不倫した人とか
なんとか理由があるんですよ
なんとかリミットがあるんですよ
これであべこべのいいところで誰でもいいんですね
殺せば  2 分以内で結構やりましたからね
だからまあもうすごい病気でね
あべこべでね それを理解して
私たちもみんなあべこべ思考を持ってますから
私は大丈夫やってことはないんです
だから気をつけて 本当にお釈迦様がおっしゃる通りに物事を考えてほしいんです
あべこべをやめてほしいんです
次に 娘さんとの付き合いはどうでしょうか
ということで やっぱりもう大人になったんだから
お母さんとしては娘を自慢してないみたいですね
我々は子供が一応独立したらもう自慢してくださいよ
うちの子はもう一人で頑張ってるんだと
あいつはなんかすごい弱気でしたけど
なかなかやってるんだ
...やってるんじゃないかっていうふうに
自分がね 自分が手塩をかけて育てたものだからね
今はもう独り立ちして勝手に生きてるんだと
これ結構頑張ってるんだということで
自分が十分自慢してないんですね
だから まあよかった よかったというね
仕事終わったというね
その満足を感じてほしいんです
親として 私はしっかり親としてやるべきことは全部やって終わった
よかったということで
今みんな勝手に頑張ってるんだと
もう関心がない もうもう何も言う必要はないんだということで
あ よかったよかったっていう気分を感じると
まあそれでいい関係が現れてくるんですね
えーどうですか？どうですかとかね
あんたご飯食べてるんですか？とかね
まあお母さん米送りますからとかね
まあそんなのは娘が頼んだらやってのをやるのはいいんだけど
でなきゃやる必要ないんですよ
で 逆もいいんですね お母さんにごちそうさせてくれよと
私はあんたにずっとご飯食べさせてあげたんだからね
今度は私にごちそうさせてくれよとかね
私ももう一年一回でもいいんだからね
ちょっと旅館で 1 日のんびりしたいんだから
お金貸してくれよとかね
そういうふうに逆にしておくと
それが素晴らしい親子関係なんですよ
子供も喜んじゃうし 自分が一人前になったんだという
すごい自信がついてくるんですね
親の面倒を見るところまで成長したもんだと
本人も楽しいんですね
親にとってはもうよく頑張ったね
私もという また充実感が生まれてくるんですね
そこが味わえないと この悪い関係がものすごく続くんですね
親離れ子離れできなくなってね
これ気持ち悪いんですね
それからまあ それからどういう関係かというと
やっぱりまあ友達関係なんですね
自分の娘さんはお母さんの友達で
先輩後輩関係ではよろしいと思いますね
えーどんどん まあ後輩はまあ
先輩を抑えますけどね
やがてそれも知った上で
先輩後輩関係にした方がまあよろしいんじゃないかなと思います
以上です この光は少々下げることはできますかね
よろしくお願いいたします
彼女がですね うつ病になってしまいまして
なんとか助け助けられたり
支えられることがないかというのをお聞きしたいです
すぐに死にたがったり
生きているのがつらいと言ったりですね
楽しくないと言ったりしてるんで
ちょうどのお話にもあったように
生きることはつらいんだよとか言ってもですね
生きる人に もうすでにつらい人にとっては
じゃあ死ぬっていうような感じになってしまうんですね
それで長老の話の本とかですね
そういうものを読んでもらおうと思ってもですね
彼女は宗教とかそういうものに対してすごい拒絶反応をする人で
そういう説 じみたものっていうのは拒絶反応が強いので聞く耳を持たないです
なので何かを押し付けることはできないので
どうしたら救える 救えるっていうんですか
伝えることができるのかなということをお聞きしたいです
はい そこまで言うならば答えは簡単ですよ
あなたは決して治りたくないしね
もうもう誰の助けも欲しくないでしょうと
だから勝手に苦しんでくださいということはないんですよね
だから結局はそういうわがままでいい加減で
まあ私こそ世界一最高やという気分でいて
そこはそうじゃないとわかると嘘になっちゃうんですね
嘘も結局は怒りで怒りでね
怒られたということになるしね
しかし まあ治したいければ本人がなんとかしてちょうだいという気分がまず必要なんですよ
人間の自由は奪えないんです
私たちはいくら親切にねと人を助けてあげたいんだけど
相手が拒否するならば
もうそれでもう終わり
話はどうにもならんです
だから生命は一人一人独立していて
自由であって 自分の意思で生きているんです
失敗はします 誰でも 私たちは何か失敗してこけたら
誰かに助けてくれよと頼むんですよ
なんとかしてよと その一言葉が必要なんです
たとえお釈迦様が自分でいらっしゃっても
その一言葉ないと何もできませんよ
お釈迦様にさえも だから弱いのいいんです
別に 失敗するのはどうったことないんです
人生こけちゃうのは構いません
誰でもやっちゃいます
嘘になったってもどうったことないんです
突然狂暴になったってもどうったことないんです
そういうのはあり得るんですが
自分がダメになったら誰かに何とかしてよと
自分ではどうにもならんよと
例えば愛虫の人がいる
勝手に愛虫から立ち直るために何もできませんよ
だからその人は俺がダメだ
なんとかしたいんだけどという一言葉が必要なんですよ
それだったらいくらでも方法はあります
人を助けてあげる方法は
ですから 一般的な答えを出しますから
嘘っていうのは怠けと怒りの結果で
自分をあまりにも高く評価していて
自分が世界一や宇宙一やと思っているんで
心の底で しかし生きてみるとすべて逆なんですね
結果は自分がいてもいなくてもどうでもいいんですね
この宇宙に対しては そこを認めたくないし
それで嘘になってしまうんですね
だいたい男性の場合は良くなりますし
女性はそんなにたくさんのいませんだけど
嘘はだいたい男性には多い病気で
男性っていうのはバリバリ仕事をしていますけど
45になってくるともう先は見えちゃいますね
もう何にでも挑戦して生きてきたのに
もう挑戦してもしても先が見えちゃうんですね
人生ってこんなもんやと
そこでちょっと落ち込んじゃうんですよ
それが嘘になっちゃうんですね
ですから この 嘘を直すためには
まずもう本人が嘘だと言っちゃうと
もう私に言われた場合はもうだいたいみんな直してあげたんですよ
私って言わないで隠した場合はもうどうにもならんです
言ってほしいんです 言ったらこの法則的に権利が成り立つのですよ
人の自由は侵せません
どうしてもこれ不可能
無理 で 相手がいいよと言ったら
まあその程度で助けてあげたりする
体を動かす方が一番先にやりやすいんですよ
ちょこちょこっとあなたの嘘を直してあげあげましょうではなくて
あの一緒に俺がジョギングしたいんだけど
一人でやる気にはならないんだよと
お願いしますから 一緒にいてくれるとかね
あんた走らなくてもいいんだからね
ちょっとそばにいてよと
そういう風にも引っ張るんですね
体を動かすために そこで一緒に歩きましょう
一緒にジョギングしましょうとかね
体を動かすとかなり脳が動いてきます
それから知識系のよくよく考える話を持っていったりとかね
例えばあなた なんで宗教は嫌いですか？とかね
それはどういう理屈でしょうかとかね
そういう風にも話したりして
それは感情であって 気持ちであって
あまり事実じゃないでしょうとかね
あるいはこういうこういう宗教はこういうことをやっているんだから
なるほど それはそうなんですけどとかね
では もう世界ではこういうこういう宗教たくさんありまして
なんででしょうかね みんなそれでも一生懸命やっているなとかね
そういうふうに知識系の話を持ってきたりとか
説教はダメなんですね
誰でも嘘であってもなくても
説教されるのは嫌ですからね
そういう感じで まず体を動かして
それから心を動かすという順番で頑張ってみればいかがでしょうかと
それでも相手を直してあげるっていうことは忘れた方がいいんですよ
そうなってくると 向こうは完全に気付います
かなり重病やと思いますけどね
なかなか今の状況では
脳が壊れて壊れてきますよ
薄くなっちゃうと だからいつでも挑戦的な生き方
いつでも何かに挑戦する
チャレンジする 何か新しいものを見つかる
何か面白いものを見つかるという生き方は決して忘れてはならないんです
そういうところで何かあの
何か助けになることがあったら受けてください
一般的な論でしか何も言えませんね
この状況では はい ありがとうございます
はい 次の質問の方は すみません
黄色くん  ありがとうございます
豊かさとは何でしょうか
幸せとは何でしょうか
2日前にカンボジアから帰国しました
首都プノンペンでは 数百万人の劣悪な環境の中で
数百万人の人々がゴミ山で暮らしていました
私の友人の若い日本の大学生がそこで数ヶ月間フィールドワークをしています
そのゴミ山で暮らしている子供たちは
わずか4  5歳でネイティブの英語をしっかりと身につけることができています
わずか12歳の少年が僕は政治家にはならないけれども
カンボジアを内部から変革するためには政治の勉強をしたいと
12歳の子供が普通に話をします
一体豊かさや幸せって何だろうとすごく心を刺されました
そういう子供が特殊なのではなくて
カンボジアにはそういう子たちがゴロゴロいるよと
その日本の大学生が言ってました
ゴミ山でダイヤの原石がゴロゴロ転がっている
それなのに日本の僕らは
そして青年たちは悩んで生き甲斐を失っています
一体本当に幸せって豊かさって何なんだろうというのが
今すごく心の中に抱えています
何か教えていただければと思います
この仏教思考でね 我々は西洋思考を信仰することになったんだから
そういう問題がなってるんですよ
西洋思考と東洋思考と分けてみると
東洋っていうのは心の世界で生きることが大事にするんですね
西洋はものを大事にするんですね
お前死んだっても品物は大事だよという
ものを大事に というね
命を大事にする どちらでしょうかと
で 西洋は完全に間違ってます
ダイヤが高価かないかということは
ダイヤが決めるんじゃなくて
生き物が決めるんです
人間がなければ ダイヤってただの石しか何でもないんです
ダイヤに価値が価値があるんじゃなくて
ダイヤに対する人間のアプローチがなんで問題は
ですから このテーブルに価値があるのかというと価値がないんです
しかし これ 人間 生き物が使っているんだから価値があるんですよ
生き物にとって価値が変わりますよ
シロアリさんにとっては
これは食べ物であって
私たちにとっては物を置くものであってという価値なんですね
だから 生きることが一番大事なことで
生きることを支えるものは
まあそれなりの価値があって
これがあべこべになっちゃって
物に価値があって 我々はものの奴隷にならなくちゃいけないんですね
例えば 今 世界の人類が飢えて飢えて飢えても OK やと賞金の取引をやっているところで
食べ物やらトウモロコシや石油やら
何でも何年ももう先取り取引やっていて
とことんわざわざと値段上げているんですね
もっと上げるだろう もっと上げるだろうとか言って
あの人々はもうもう神よりも恐ろしいんですね
人類を破壊しようとしている
自分の金のために そんなことはもう極限に悪行為なんですけど
しかし 法律も作りません
そんなことやめようとかね
先物取引やめましょうとか
もう世界的にやる合理的な値段にしておきましょうと
石油の値段が上げて悪くはないんだけど
合理的にゆっくりとじわじわと上げなくちゃいけないし
これはサプライとデマンドの関係で成り立つものでしょうし
そんなこと何もない サプライは十分あるのに値段だけ上がったりして
それで第三世界と日本も困りますからね
食べ物はなくなったりして
人が死んだって知ったもんか
そんなのはと それより金が大事だと
だから この物質文明を受けちゃうと
人間が幸福でそれ払わなくちゃいけないんですよ
日本の若者も 自分が生きる喜びを払って品物を買うんです
だから生きることは苦しいし
頭が悪いし うまくいかなかったら人を殺したりもするし
ゴミの山で生活しても
そういう子供たちが喜んで生きているんですよ
生きる喜びだけはたったそれしかないんだからね
よく笑っちゃうんですね
で 昔テレビでタイですごい洪水があって
もうみんなものすごく被害を受けたこと
ケースが NHK で流れてあって
そこでこの屋根の上から子供たちを小さなボートで連れていくんですよ
もう安全なところに 自分の家が潰れてるのに
子供たちはもうボートでも手を振りながら
わいわいと笑って カメラに手を振ってあげたりとかね
全然悩みがないんですよ
その洪水で楽しもうと
子供たちはふざけてそこを楽しんでるんですよ
だから 家が大事だと思っちゃうと楽しめないんですよ
はぁ なんてことか 私の家にも水が入っちゃって
もうどうしようもないんだ
これをお金どうしようかとかね
だから 物を神様にするか
心を神様にするかっていうことなんですよ
心を生きることを喜び
生きる喜びを知っている人の頭がいいんです
すごく立派なことを考えちゃうんですよ
カンボジアの場合は もうさすが素晴らしい国だと私は思いますよ
なぜならば あれほど kemarinうちにやられて
あれほど殺されて殺されて
村の同じ人が おじいさんが自分を密告してたくさん親戚を殺していたのに
今みんな仲良くして生活しているんです
もう司会はしません  それは仏教の影響ですからね
しかししたら罰が当たると知ってるんだから
とにかく私たちは生きる喜びを失っていますよ
だから 払ったものより買ってるものはとんでもないものですよ
家を買ったっても 自分の家になれないし
家は潰れるし 死ぬ時は置いておかなくちゃいけないし
パソコンとか買ったっても
だいたい半年になってくると動かなくなっちゃうし
そんなにも品物を宗教にするんですかね
だから豊かさっていうのは心の喜びなんです
充実感なんです 心の楽しみなんです
物じゃないんです ものが心の楽しみをなくしちゃうんです
じゃあ もう時間はないんですけど
あるジャータカ物語り
お釈迦様の物語を紹介します
えーと 昔 ある国で王様がいて
王様がもう国の全財産は王様のものだから
ものすごく豊かででっかい宮殿を作って生活しているんです
しかし この王様が仕事がありすぎちゃって
大変困っているんですね
安らぎがないんです そこで毎日
この王様は夜 楽器を弾いて人が歌っているのが聞こえるんです
とてもきれいな声で とても楽しく喜んで歌っているんですね
王様ももうくたくたし
ストレス溜まって疲れていて
夜窓を開けてこの歌声を聞いてるんですね
それで羨ましくなるんですね
あの人はなんて楽しいでしょうかと
何も悩むことなく 喜んで歌っているでしょうと
だから 私よりも幸福なやつがこの国にいるとはと思ったんです
思って 自分の家来に頼んだんです
夜10時ぐらいになってくると
人が毎日楽器を弾いて歌ってますよ
その人を誰かと調べてくださいと
ただ 家来の人は調べたんです
この人は 1円も持ってないホームレスなんです
いるところがなくて 夜みんな町の門とか全部閉めたら
この町の壁に だから夜しか来られません
みんな追い出しますからね
警備の人々やらね そこで町の壁に何か屋根ちょこっとありますから
その中にちょこっと体を寄せているだけ
だから夜 すごい夜でないとその場所には行けないんです
そちらに行って まあ楽器を弾いて歌っているんですね
何もないんです しかし
人生は楽しく生きているんです
それで王様がそこを聞いて
あの人あれほど喜んで歌っていて
お金もないんだから じゃあいいことしましょうと言って
次の日 かなりお金の...まあ昔は金貨ですからね
でっかい袋をたくさん作っておいて
その人に王様がくれたっていうことでもなく
ちょこっと渡してあげてくださいと言ったらあげたんです
王様の計算は この人はもう乞食やらなくてもいい
もう大金入ったんだから
すごい立派な家を買って贅沢でいればいい
そうするともっと美しく歌うだろうと
悩むことないんだから
違ったんです それっきりで歌声がなくなっちゃったんです
その人は歌えなくなっちゃったんです
これ お金どうしようかと
今までは乞食で生きていたんだから
今更家買って売ってくる人もいないし
豪華に食べようと思って店に行ったっても追い出されるし
だからといってお金を持っていると誰かに殺されるでしょうし
だから夜寝られなくなっちゃったんです
心配で 歌うところでなくなっちゃったんです
それでやがてこの人は何したのかというと
お願いしますから 王様
私は幸福に生きていきたいんだから
このお金を逆にもらってくださいと言って返したそうです
そのジャータカ物語は
幸福はどこにあるのかということは物語っているんです
ダンマパダ [applause]今日はどうもありがとうございます
[applause]